Ніщо не заважає почати з ось таких картинок.
Шкода лише, що олені не мають до цієї історії жодного відношення.
А йдеться у ній про бетонні будівельні об'єкти.
І про те, що сниться уночі людям, які мешкають у таких будинках.
А сняться їм, можливо, дерева і просіки, ліс та його мешканці.
Тому не дивно, що дехто прагне жити не в бетоні, а у… деревині.
За деякими даними, майже кожен п'ятий новий будинок у Німеччині - з дерева. І ось чому.
Той, хто заходить у таку дерев'яну квартиру,
майже завжди приголомшений якістю та атмосферою цієї квартири.
Якщо ви зайдете в готовий дерев'яний будинок, ви з першого ж дня
зможете почуватися там комфортно з точки зору будівельної фізики
і мати зовсім іншу атмосферу життя.
Власне, такі відчуття мають виникати тут, у "WoHo",
найвищому дерев'яному житловому будинку Німеччини.
98 метрів, 29 поверхів.
Нині такі пілотні проєкти реалізуються по всьому світу.
Берлін не може залишатись обабіч.
Берлін вирішив побудувати цілий квартал з дерева - квартал Курта Шумахера.
Шкільні будівлі тут будуватимуться повністю з дерева. І певною мірою це виправдано.
Ми повинні почати втілювати кліматичну нейтральність у містах.
І в цьому, звичайно, допомагає деревина як будматеріал.
Дерево століттями зв'язує CO2. І коли воно вбудовується, воно "дихає".
І це вирішальна відмінність від бетону.
Так, все правильно. Бетон шкідливий для клімату.
Цементна промисловість, така важлива для виробництва бетону,
в 2019 році спричинила втричі більше викидів,
ніж всі глобальні авіаперевезення, зазначає Міжурядова комісія з питань зміни клімату.
А тепер питання "на засипку": Яку частку глобальних викидів СО2 спричиняє будівництво та використання будинків?
Згідно з доповіддю ООН - 38 відсотків.
Бетон все ще є стандартом у будівництві.
І інший квартал у Берліні наразі будується повністю з бетону.
Лише один будинок має бути частково дерев'яним. Ось як це виглядатиме.
"Гібридний" будинок зведуть до кінця цього року.
Бетонна основа та сходи, решта - деревина.
Архітектор Фарід Шарабі займається проєктами з деревини це вже більше десяти років,
він був одним із перших у Берліні.
Ми були першопрохідцями. І потерпали, як потерпають першопрохідці.
Нам довелося прокласти шлях, подолати багато перешкод, довелося протистояти
великому опору, зокрема у владі. Ми зібрали команду фахівців-планувальників.
Звісно, клієнтів також довелося переконувати.
Спочатку все було непросто.
Це один з найновіших проєктів "зеленого" архітектора.
Шестиповерхова конструкція із суцільного дерева на приблизно 40 квартир.
Архітектор та його команда вийшли у фінал
Німецької премії сталого розвитку 2021 року.
Скажу відверто: наше бюро вирішило будувати з деревини зовсім
не з екологічних міркувань. Це було в 2007 році.
Мабуть, вперше думка про це промайнула у мене в 2005 році.
Мене вразило, наскільки це гарно. А те, що це також надзвичайно екологічно
і що деревина вбирає СО2, та ще й у значних кількостях,
це прозріння, чесно кажучи, прийшло лише згодом.
Перспективність дерев'яних багатоповерхівок пов'язана не лише
з їхньою екологічністю. Вони також не повинні бути житлом виключно для супербагатих.
Всі соціальні класи у будинку повинні жити разом.
Це проживання по сусідству, це комунальне життя. Якщо ви в'їжджаєте
у такий об'єкт, ви повинні мати певну позицію.
Оскільки деревина живе, вона рухається, дерево тріскається,
ви повинні вміти з цим поводитися, і ви також маєте цього хотіти.
Щоправда, чи виправдовує таке житло вирубку дерев?
Що у цьому екологічного, запитаєте ви.
Правильно - це не вирубувати так, щоб більше нічого не могло вирости.
Ми повинні селективно використовувати ресурси, які маємо в Німеччині
та Центральній Європі. Якщо ігнорувати це, то, безумовно, таке будівництво
буде не таким кліматичним, як нам би цього хотілося.
Крім того, через засухи у Німеччині нині профіцит деревини на ринку.
Тут на будмайданчику в центрі Берліна
за 5 років має вирости у небо нова дерев'яна багатоповерхівка.